اذا البدايه من التطورات في السودان حيث
نشر اعلام مجلس السياده صورا تظهر رئيس
المجلس قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان في
جوله ميدانيه وهو يتفقد قوات للجيش ووفق
اعلام السياده فان هذه الصور للبرهان
بالقرب من مقر القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه ظهور البرهان ياتي على وقع
اشتباكات ضاريه في مناطق عده بالخرطوم
ينضم الينا من ام درمان مراسل الجزيره
هيثم اويت للحديث عن التطورات المدنيه
والظهور الميداني للبرهان ومعانيه على
الصعيد العسكري وصعيد السيطره الميدانيه
هيثم
نعم بطبيعه الحال هذا الزهور لقائد الجيش
السوداني الرئيس مجلس السياده هو الظهور
الاول له وسط جنوده كان طبعا البرهان كان
قد ظهر قبل ذلك في غرفه عمليات وهو يدير
العمليات العسكريه بجانب الفريق اول شمس
الدين كباشي وعدد من قاده الجيش وكان ايضا
قد ظهر في وهو يهنئ الشعب السوداني بحلول
عيد الفطر المبارك ولكن هذا هو الظهور
الاول له بين جنوده وهو يتفقد الجنود في
مقر القياده العامه للجيش وهو يحمل بندقيه
قنص وايضا يحمي المسدسا موازيا عسكريا
للعمليات فيما يشير الى انه بهذه بهذا
الظهور طبعا لديه اكثر من دلاله واكثر من
اشاره بانه موجود وسط جنينه يدير هذه
العمليات العسكريه بنفسه وانه ايضا يقوم
بتفقد القوات في مقر القياده العامه في
اشاره الى السيطره الكامله لهذه الساحه
التي كانت في لفتره طويله في اطار
المشاهدات الاعلاميه والبيانات المختلفه
بين الجانبين
من يسيطر على هذه المنطقه وكذلك ايضا
محيطا لهذه القياده العامه باعتبار ان
الجيش الان يبسط سيطرته على تلك المناطق
وايضا
فيها ايضا اشاره لرفع الروح المعنويه
لقوات الجيش التي ايضا كانت هناك طبعا
حديثه اكثر من مره صرح به قائد القوات
الدعم السريع بان قائد الجيش مختفي في
مكان ما تحت الارض وهذا ظهور ربما هو يعني
رد لي هذه الايداعات التي كانت تقال قبل
اليوم وبالتالي هذا ظهور له العديد من
الرسائل سواء كانت العسكريه الميدانيه هو
ايضا ربما سياسيه وهذا الظهور ياتي في خضم
معارك ما تزال مستمره نعم هذه المعارك
المستمره هل لنا ان نعرف هيثم الى اين
وصلت وهل تغير شيء على ارض الواقع
المعارك طبعا ما تزال مستمره بين قوات
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
اكثر من موقع في سواء كان في الخرطوم او
منطقه الخرطوم بحري تحديدا ام درمان تشهد
نوعا ما من الهدوء ولكن هذه المعارك
والوتيره التي تستمر بها طبعا هي معارك
حربي مدن وهناك عمليات قصف جوي يقوم بها
سلاح الجو للجيش بشكل مستمر على مواقع
القوات الدعم السريع والتي هي بالتقوم
بالرد بمضادات الارضيه التي تمتلكها
للدفاع عن مواقع التي تتمترز فيها وايضا
هناك الهجمات في الكثير من المواقع
المقر سواء كانت العسكريه او في المدن
خاصه في منطقه شمال البحري بالامس التي
شهدت مواجهات داميه في منطقه الكادرو
وايضا هناك كان حديث عن السيطره القوات
الدعم السريع بحسب بيانها على معسكر للجيش
معسكر السواقه وايضا منطقه الدفاع الجوي
وايضا هناك بيانات اخرى من الجيش كانت قد
قالت انهم استعادوا السيطره على هذه
المواقع تظل يعني المشهد الميداني يظل
يشهد مناوشات والاشتباكات متقطعه من وقت
الى اخر في في ظل حتى الان يعني عدم وجود
يعني اتجاه لوجود اتفاق حقيقي لوقت اطلاق
النار رغم المنشدات او التفاهمات الجاريه
في جده بطريقه غير مباشره هيثم درمان شكرا
جزيلا لك